joining us now with reaction is the
missouri senator josh hawley senator why
you had to say to them
and remind them why can't they
acknowledge that they did abandon our
fellow americans they abandoned hundreds
we don't have an exact number one point
in the hearing today
one of the people testifying actually
said i it could be as high as four
thousand i don't know how many americans
were abandoned i can't say
um then we abandoned green card holders
then we abandoned their families and we
abandoned our afghan allies all behind
enemy lines and it's 45 days senator you
see a lot of hope getting them home
you know not based on what i'm hearing
sean and here's the real reason why
won't they why won't they admit it it's
because they don't want to take any
responsibility general milley doesn't
want any responsibility austin doesn't
want responsibility and most of all joe
biden doesn't want to take any
responsibility but it's time that they
did which is why all those guys should
resign milly needs to resign austin
needs to resign i mean millie he's
sitting here trading gossip with bob
woodward while afghanistan literally
burns literally burns
the accountability's got to start right
there he needs to resign austin needs to
resign the president should fire you
said that to austin don't tell me we're
not leaving americans behind why did you
have to remind him of that
you know it's just extraordinary that he
would sit there and tell the committee
because what he said sean was is that we
haven't we haven't left americans behind
he said that he's under oath and he
actually said that you know what it's a
joe biden talking point i mean joe
biden's white house has said that oh we
didn't actually leave americans behind
guess what we're not in afghanistan the
american civilians still are many of our
fellow citizens still there still
trapped and they're denying it the
administration's denying it it is just
shameful for that reason alone austin
and millie ought to resign did we ever
get an answer to a plan to try and
rescue our fellow americans that they
abandon is there any plan
in place to try to get them out because
the last time i heard from tony blinken
he actually said if you have a chartered
flight with americans on it you're not
allowed to land in the united states if
you get a third party country to accept
your charter
that's fine but if you need our approval
it will not be forthcoming why wouldn't
we allow a plane chartered with american
citizens on it to land in america to get
him the hell out of that hell hole of
afghanistan run by terrorists
i have no earthly idea and you're
absolutely right in terms of there not
being a plan if there is one i didn't
hear about it today and here's the other
thing sean we also learned today that
the reason all those americans our
fellow citizens got left behind is
because joe biden waited too long to
order an evacuation he didn't have the
guts to order an evacuation when there
needed to be one he allowed our military
to draw down to zero with american
civilians all still there and when they
needed to be evacuated he wouldn't do it
he was worried about how it would look
and now here we are americans are left
behind he has abandoned them 13 soldiers
dead that's joe biden's record let me
put up on the screen you probably can't
see it i'll explain what it is it's a
map of afghanistan from the southern
portion all those red sections you can
see the corresponding dates may june and
then july when in july by the way when
when joe biden was saying that the
military some of the best trained in the
world they had over 60 percent of the
country they've been on the march for
months and everybody knew it was
happening joe never fired a single drone
shot to push him back and nor did he
move up the date when we had control of
kabul to safely evacuate every american
every green card holder every family
member and every afghan ally and it
would have been nice if we took our
billions of dollars in sophisticated
weaponry with us as well senator
that's exactly right you know when biden
says stuff like oh nobody saw this
coming that is simply false you can look
right there at the the facts that you
put on the screen the taliban was in a
major offensive beginning in the early
spring his own general on the ground
warned him warned biden that the afghan
government would fall and yet biden did
nothing he didn't order an evacuation he
didn't get american citizens out he
waited he dithered he didn't have the
guts to do it when he should have done
it and now because of that we have
americans who are traveling biden wide
and americans died
fair
biden lied and americans are held
hostages fair
okay senator thank you that is the fact